wednesday edition of p-f-t-o-t he's
peter king i'm mike florio and there is
one topic in particular that we're gonna
get to today i brought it up very
briefly at the end of one of our
segments the possibility that the nfl
will encounter a situation in which some
stadiums can be open this year but some
stadiums can't be open for example in a
place like california where governor
gavin newsom has
suggested along with other politicians
there that it may be a while until
stadiums can open up and fans can attend
one idea that i had yesterday peter and
one thing i'm going to be looking at
very carefully when the schedule comes
out
will the nfl potentially in advance
build in
the possibility of
say
the rams
sharing a venue with the raiders in las
vegas the chargers sharing with the
cardinals in arizona the 49ers may be
going to denver and sharing with the
broncos i want to see when the home
games for some of these teams line up to
see if there is a way
that it could be accommodating if it's
been planned in advance for this
possibility the nfl will say we'd rather
take
these games to a place where fans can
attend and we can make money that way
versus playing the games in a sterile
empty stadium your thoughts on the
possibility that the nfl is considering
having teams share stadiums for this one
crazy year of nfl football
i don't know whether they are or not
mike but i i would like to advance one
thing that a
top
team official said to me over the
weekend when i was writing my column for
monday on what the nfl could look like
in 2020 and i didn't write this it's a
little bit of inside baseball but it
gives you sort of an idea of how
different the nfl could be
and that is
the the the option that in many cases
nfl teams could travel day of game
to to their to their games
so for instance
if the new york jets uh are playing uh
the cleveland browns the jets just wake
up on sunday morning and they have a 7
30 a.m flight to cleveland they go
directly to the stadium in cleveland and
they're in the locker room no later than
9 45 which is about when the first bus
would arrive anyway um you know from the
hotel and so i could see that happening
this year
where unless you're on uh you know say a
two or three time zone trip that you
don't travel the day before the game and
i only bring that up because it is a
little bit insideish i only bring that
up because i think
teams are going to get half are going to
have to get used to doing things
much differently in 2020 logistically
than in any other year they've had and
it won't just be the travel day of game
it might be as you suggest
teams combining stadiums if say a team
in california cannot play at their home
stadium until let's say december 1st i'm
totally inventing that but if a team
can't play until then
they're going to have to play their home
game somewhere so who knows
could they fly to uh arizona for their
home games and play
three or four home games and then get
their home schedule back loaded so maybe
their last five games are at home but i
think you're right mike those are the
kind of things that i would be looking
for when the schedule comes out this
week
you know and peter another thing that is
unrelated to how the schedule will be
configured but when it comes down to it
and and i know that there would be
logistical challenges here as well but
if you're going to play in an empty
stadium why not just play in a practice
facility right do you need to play in a
stadium at all if it's if no one's going
to be there i mean there are different
places these games can be played more
efficiently more effectively with fewer
people there than opening a stadium just
for the purposes of having 22 football
players on the field so you know it's
it's like everything else with this
every answer results in another question
and you know i like the idea of teams
traveling day of game but what if a
flight gets delayed what if there was a
snowstorm that morning and the team
doesn't get there on time there was this
story this year about the chief's gear
ending up in the wrong spot in advance
of a game against the patriots i think
it was you know it doesn't take much to
screw everything up but i think your
core message and kind of what i'm
getting at as well
the reality that this is a year where
flexibility is going to be key
and we know that coaches are creatures
of habit well what's happened the last
couple of months has ripped that
away from them and forced them to do
things a different way and i think
whoever can adjust on the fly to
whatever curveball screw ball gets
thrown at them that's the team that's
going to make it that's the team that's
going to thrive the team that can take
all of the changes roll with the punches
and be ready to play football whenever
wherever however the games get played
mike i'm going to tell you something
that you are going to say my god peter
is gone off the deep end but i'm going
to tell you a story
about
my daughter's montclair high school
field hockey season 15 years ago
and
they were supposed to have a new field
installed at their home field a field
turf field and one thing led to another
and another and another and it never
ended up getting installed that year so
the team did not have a home field they
played their entire season on the road
and you know what happened they used
that
as the motivating force for their season
their coach used that they ended up
going to the final four of the state and
field hockey that year and my only point
is not that oh good if the 49ers only
play two games at home then they're
going to the super bowl again i'm not
saying that but i'm saying that coaches
are very very good at using obstacles as
motivating factors and i would expect
that to happen all season throughout the
nfl
yeah we have a limited sample size of
that as the nfl goes the saints in 2005
after hurricane katrina had no home
games and their coaching staff and their
players were trying to operate on the
road while worrying about people at home
and look it just didn't go well for the
saints last year but they were the only
ones this year you're going to have to
some extent every team affected in some
way you can't get into a disparity where
if the virus is more prevalent in one
portion of the country and teams are
still playing games versus other
portions of the country but but you're
right the best coaches will take
whatever is dropped in front of them and
mold that into
something that can be used to get his
guys motivated and focused and ready to
perform under any circumstances i mean
we hear coaches say all the time well
we'll go out and play in the parking lot
if we have to i don't know who i'm
imitating there but that's what you know
okay well this is maybe you're going to
be playing in the parking lot this year
who knows where in the hell you're going
to be playing and who knows when you're
going to find out you just got to be
ready to go anytime anyplace anywhere
and you know what in a weird sort of a
way yeah i wish we weren't obviously
dealing with the pandemic but in a weird
sort of a way
it makes this season more compelling if
we go into it not knowing how in the
hell it's going to play out who's going
to get screwed who's going to get the
benefit and how these teams are going to
adapt to all these
constantly changing circumstances
mike you know i i don't say this all too
la i don't say it very loud okay but
it's something that i feel the last five
or six weeks have been the most
interesting time in my 40 years as a
sports writer
because everything is new everything is
weird everything is different
and you know i i sat in on the tampa bay
buccaneers first round of the draft
watching their general manager in his
kids toy room at his home in tampa
i mean that's just we're seeing things
that just aren't going to happen again
and i try not to say
gee this is fun but i mean if you were
in the business
and you understand what is happening in
the outside world it's a little bit
insensitive to complain that oh yeah you
know we can't we we might not have all
our home games this year or we might
have to go play somewhere else i i and
again
on sunday night this coach called me
began it was too late my column was done
he called me late sunday night and i
told him what i was writing and he and
he said to me the exact words that i
think everybody in the nfl should be
saying right now well hey thank god we
all got jobs and that's kind of the way
when you get slapped in the face
this year
with something that is totally unjust
and unfair
big deal wow
and the other thing too that the nfl
realizes and and look sometimes your
selfish interests and any sense of
altruism coincidentally intersect and
with the nfl yeah they want to play
these games they want to make the money
the players want to get paid the coaches
want to get paid the nfl doesn't want to
go a season without football but at the
same time it does help the people who
are dealing with the pandemic it gives
us something to look forward to whether
it's the draft whether it's the schedule
release whether it's the games whether
fans are there or not whether the
chargers are playing in arizona or not
whatever the case may be it's something
that we can look forward to because i
think we all understand regardless of
all the noise and the fights and the
debates and the demonstrations we all
know that the rest of this year is going
to be different than any other year
we've experienced we just don't know how
it's going to be different so if there
is that threat of a football season that
runs through every year we've seen and
makes it through this year that's good
for everyone's overall mental well-being
so even though the nfl benefits directly
financially we benefit football fans
benefit because it gives us something
in this wasteland of groundhog day that
that we hope or at least we know is
going to be there in some form or
fashion
mike i think i do think it's it's a
cliche you know i live in new york and i
watch a lot of these andrew cuomo
sessions on television every morning he
goes on for about an hour and i watch
him and he basically
has said in 48 different ways
we are going to come out of this as
stronger people
and i totally agree with him these
hardships that we're not used to dealing
with i mean some people have real
hardships and some people are dying and
so i think we all have to consider
that
damn it we are lucky to live in this
country i am i am i am
i'm so i'm so proud when i look i'm
walking my dog in brooklyn new york and
i pass by 30 people and they're all
wearing masks and they all when you come
when you're going to pass somebody on a
sidewalk
they go as far as they can to one side i
go as far as i can it's just simply
being considerate
and this is not going to last forever
but as long as it lasts
i got to tell you i'm um what i've seen
in my world you know i'm proud of people
and i think we're going to come out of
this
uh being proud of each other whenever
all is said and done
well said peter and we'll end it on that
note we'll be back on thursday with
another edition of pro football talk
live check out the peter king podcast
wherever podcasts are available for the
larry zonka interview football morning
in america still plenty of stuff in
there if you haven't read it yet this
week new one coming on monday new pft
live tomorrow we'll talk to everybody
soon have a safe and happy wednesday
we'll see you
[Music]
thursday hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports